[Musik]
also wenn ich das jedes mal wer da
kriege ich auch gern ich war vor einigen
tagen auf youtube unterwegs und habe
dort dieses video entdeckt namens ich
teste di luca pizza drei schmeckt wie
das video hat 5577 aufruf und würde
hochgeladen von dem user apple schorle
mit 2220 abonnenten und einem profilbild
mit einem glas wasser und einem apple lg
drauf alles klar dann habe ich auf jeden
fall auf das video drauf geklickt und
habe mir als aller erstes mal die
bewertungen angeschaut und die sehen wie
folgt aus ja nicht so berauschend
allerdings habe ich mich von den
schlechten bewertungen überhaupt nicht
in die irre führen lassen und indirekte
die kommentar sektion gewandert wo ich
mir dann einige kommentare zu gemüte
geführt habe und die lese ich euch jetzt
mal vor autismus auf dem höchsten level
mann bist du lustig was habe ich mir da
angesehen
wie tief kann man sinken wtf wo bin ich
hier gelandet
es enthält preisträger was sein und
gestik junge trägst du es nicht wir
lachen nicht mit dir auch nicht über
dich wir schämen uns einfach nur für
dich wenn nicht die reinen ja und der
letzte kommentar den ich dann gesehen
haben unter dem video den fand ich
besonders toll und zwar deine stimme ist
schwul und luca ist auch schwul
das stimmt nicht allerdings habe ich
mich dann auch nicht von den negativen
kommentaren in die irre führen lassen
sondern haben weiter mir die videodaten
angeschaut wie beispielsweise die
kategorie
das ist nämlich musik und dann bin ich
ein wenig hellhörig geworden denn
normalerweise wenn man rennt mit pizza
testet oder irgendetwas anderes test
oder keine ahnung was das ist irgendeine
kategorie aber nicht musik sondern er
hatte eventuell musik einfach als
standard
die gori für seine uploads ausgewählt
und daher habe ich mir gedacht hey wer
ist denn dieser apple schade weil der
der über 2000 abonnenten und vielleicht
könntest ja in krasser musiker sein den
ich irgendwie noch nicht so richtig
kenne bin ich auf seinem youtube kanal
gegangen und habe mir sein titel bild
angeschaut und das ist das hier das ist
ja ein apfel saftschorle was auch immer
kreativ ja okay ich brauche nicht sagen
dass sie ist das ist mein youtube will
jedoch habe ich mir dann ein wenig
genauer den youtube kanal von apple show
angeschaut und was einem als erstes ins
auge sticht und seine zahlreichen
playlisten die beispielsweise ananas
quad oder saft gibt kraft oder auch
schorle new wave ich meine wer kennt
diese ganzen playlisten nicht doch dann
bin ich rüber gegangen zu sein videos
und das erste video was mir ins auge
gestoßen ist war apple schorle
auberginen produced by me you also das
ist anscheinend irgendeinen song den
herausgebracht hat und das hat mir
gezeigt okay wenn das pizza testen video
die kategorie musik hat dann ist er
wahrscheinlich wirklich sänger von daher
habe ich dann mal auf den song
auberginen drauf geklickt und das waren
die bewertungen ich meine vielleicht
haben diese 1555 dislike eventuell
einfach nicht wissen und musikgeschmack
voreilig beschreibung angeschaut und
darin steht einfach das hier apple
unterstrich schorle 428 instagram und ja
ihr kennt mich ich bin dann auch auf
seine instagram profil gegangen
der der deine mami klärt keine ahnung
was deinen instagram für einen sinn hat
aber okay meine damen und herren ich bin
weiter unvoreingenommen und habe dann
hier endlich mal sein lied angehört weil
wir sind immer noch auf dem weg dahin
herauszufinden warum die zu ein krasser
künstler plötzlich eine luca pizza drei
review hoch aber ich würde sagen ich
spiele euch einfach mal die ersten
sekunden des lieds auberginen von apple
schon ab
ja das ist also da kann es fühlen kann
da komplett seine sachen koffer packen
und ab zum mond fliegen
ja
also ich habe jetzt nichts verstanden
habe ich glaube auch das war spanisch
allerdings drop sie jetzt dann der beat
tatsächlich bzw der was so richtig rein
[Musik]
wirklich ich habe vergessen dass ich mal
wieder heute nicht im stehen aufnehme
allerdings fängt der liebe apple schon
jetzt so richtig an zu rappen also da
hören wir auch mal rein
ok
seine lila wie auberginen wir hören mal
weiter mein name nicht in der schule
hatte ich die guten noten
sagen rapper nicht sonst machen die
chance sich in der schule waren und wie
geil sie jetzt sind also der user apple
schauen bzw
der red dot apple schon er sieht das
ganze so ein bisschen umgekehrt bin ich
interessante herangehensweise wir haben
mal weiter
[Musik]
und lass das preisschild dran weil ich
mir das leisten kann
ja wieder
noch nicht machen
[Musik]
zwischendurch verstehe ich auch einfach
kein einziges wort geredet
[Musik]
ja so sehe ich das auch allerdings
kommen wir jetzt schon zu den letzten
sekunden des liedes wohl nochmal richtig
lyrisches meisterwerk raushaut habe
gerät also wenn ich das jetzt kriege ich
auch gern das ist wirklich hammer wenn
leute wieder raus bringen und dadurch
ihre träume verwirklichen vor allem wenn
leute so viel gesangstalent haben wie
dieser apple schorlemer allerdings bin
ich dann auf jeden fall zurückgegangen
auf seinem youtube kanal und habe eine
neue playlist entdeckt die mir vorher
noch nicht so richtig aufgefallen war
die pläne strikt nämlich den namen
tiergeräusche
da denkt man sich jetzt vielleicht im
ersten moment okay ist hat irgendwie ein
album von ihm gewesen wo er jedes lied
gegen wie mal so ein bisschen aggressiv
gerappt hat wie sondern löwe und dann
war wieder so ein bisschen loki wir
irgendwie ein faultier oder so nein es
sind wirklich tiergeräusche die
hochgeladen hat wie beispielsweise von
einem schwein hier als erstes
ja
er macht dort einfach selbst
tiere nach
als nicht
ein kamel
keine ahnung welches kamel so klingt
aber als nächstes haben wir einen
schnurrenden geparden
hört sich eher nach dir beim schlafen an
allerdings vielleicht kann das sehr
koala jetzt retten doch die klassische
geräusch was ein koala halt macht
allerdings kommt jetzt noch die giraffe
und jetzt der gesang von einem
blau-weissen oder auch nach gemacht er
sehe jetzt mal kurz die wirklich wild
hog meine lieben freunde das war
wirklich der prozess nicht durchlaufen
binden mehr oder weniger bis ich mir
dann das video-interview kapitza drei
schmeckt sie von apple schorle
angeschaut habe also ich hab mir erstmal
seinen kanal angeschaut und das habe ich
euch jetzt gerade ja auch noch mal
gezeigt von daher starten wir jetzt mit
dem eigentlichen thema des videos und
zwar der reviews luca pizza 3
redet er extra so krass am arsch wollen
den an jetzt extra man extra für uns
probiert jetzt aber die strecke gut weil
youtube
[Musik]
danke das freut mich zu hören
ok dann fang mal schmeckt der käse aus
77 oder neun sorten käse drauf wir haben
sieben oder neun arten hilfe ruft
[Musik]
es freut mich zu hören dass du di luca
witz a3 anscheinend sehr sehr lecker
findet beziehungsweise uns in deinem
deinen worten wiederzugeben sehr sehr
nahe aber wir schauen uns mal weiter
seine luca pizza drei review an
nee das ist kein frischkäse degas haben
wir haben chandler mentaler gouda
mascarpone ricotta und
noch käse drauf ich kriege immer noch in
sechs aufzuzählen was den hier besser
wäre ohne das er ist aber es geht ja gar
nicht welcher trinken wir eine milch
danke dass du uns noch mal den witz
erklärt hast mit frischkäse und fisch
käse aber ja wie du selbst schon gesagt
hast fische trinken er keine milch aber
er lohnt sich vor allem als alle
vernetzten ist die sonst
danke
das freut mich wirklich zu hören die
sache deswegen wir auf der einen seite
habe ich halt seinen kanal gesehen und
dachte mir so was ist das für ein
vollidiot so aber jetzt gucke design
review und er schmeichelt mir und der
pizza die ganze zeit da denke ich mir
sowieso zu groß sei
das krieg ich war auch da sind nicht
deine mutter
damit ist das video tatsächlich dann
auch vorbei ja und damit wir auch mal
wieder für heute vorbei meine lieben
freunde ich habe das video vorgeschlagen
bekommen habe mir gedacht hey bevor ich
mir irgendwie alleine anschaue lade ich
mir das einfach runter und wir schauen
uns ein bisschen eigener in den kanal
von apple scholle an weil ich für den
kanal auf jeden fall mega unterhaltsam
ich weiß nicht ob ihr unterhalt zusammen
sein möchte aber es ist auf jeden fall
genau mein ding humor findet den kanal
von apple schorle 428 auf jeden fall
unten in der beschreibung verlegen schon
gerne bei ihm vorbei schaut euch auch
gern seine weiteren tiergeräusche videos
an diesen hammer
das ist ein biologisches quality
entertainment sandig apple schorle falls
du das hier sehen sollte sich auf jeden
fall übertrieben kannst ja mal auf mein
video hier antworten auf deinem kanal
wirklich auf jeden fall freuen mir das
video dann anzuschauen und wenn euch das
video hier gefallen hat und ich mich
sehr sehr wohl bei einem daumen hoch von
euch unter dem video ihr freund schreibt
mir gerne und in die kommentare
irgendwas lustiges weil dann kommt ihr
eventuell in mein auto weil ein lustiger
kommentar packe ich jetzt immer in
meinen augen
[Musik]